hello everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on how to
install mysql on windows 10 by simply
learn
in this session we will learn how to
install mysql workbench
and then we will run some commands so
hey everyone
i am abhisaruja from simply learn and
welcome to this video on how to install
mysql
on windows 10 but before begin if you
love watching tech videos subscribe to
our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update
so let's start
firstly we will visit the official
oracle website
that is mysql.com and now we'll move to
the downloads page
now scroll down and click on my sql
gpl downloads now under community
downloads click on my sql installer for
windows
the current versions are available to
download
i will choose this installer and click
the download button
now here just click on no things just
start my download
once the installer has downloaded open
it
you may be prompted for permission click
yes
this opens the installer you will be
asked to choose the setup type
we will go with custom
click next now you have to select the
products you want to install
we will install only the mysql server
mysql shell
and the mysql workbench expand my sql
servers by double clicking on it
and choose the version you want to
install and click on this arrow
now you have to do the same thing for
applications
expand applications
and choose the my sequel workbench
version you want to install
and click on the arrow and we'll do the
same thing for mysql shell
and choose the latest version click on
the arrow
these are the products that have to be
installed in a
now i will click next now click
execute to download and install the
server
this may take a while depending on your
internet speed
as the download is completed click next
now you see the product configuration
click next now we'll configure our sql
server instance
here we will go with the default
settings and click next
and under authentication select use
strong password encryption for
authentication which is recommended and
click on next
now we have set the password for your
root user by the way
root is the default user this user will
have access to everything
i will set my password
now i'll click on next
and here also we'll keep the default
settings
and click on next now
to apply configuration we will execute
the process
once all the configuration steps are
complete click finish
now you will see the installation is
complete it will launch my sequel
workbench and my sql shell after
clicking on finish
now the shell and workbench has started
now will connect by clicking on the root
user it will ask for a password
enter the password and it will connect
successfully
now the workbench has started now we'll
just connect the server
so first we'll open command prompt
now we will reach the path where mysql
files are present
i'm going to this pc
local disk c program files
my mysql my sql server 8.0
bin and i'll copy this path
now i'll open the command prompt and
write a command cd
space and paste the link and press enter
now i'll write another command that will
be my sequel
minus u space
root minus p and press enter
now it will ask for password just enter
the password
and press enter now the server has
started
and now we'll see some commands in my
sql workbench
first we will open my sql workbench
now we will click on the local instance
mysql 80
and enter the password to connect to the
local host
now the my sequel workbench has started
now we'll see some commands
the first command we will see is show
databases
show databases semicolon and now we'll
select the whole command
and click on this execute button
and here we will see the result in the
result grid
these are the databases that are stored
already in the database
now there are four databases that is
information schema mysql performance
schema and s5s
now we will select one of the database
we'll use mysql
now we have selected the mysql database
and now in this database we will see
which tables are stored in this mysql
database
to see that you will run a command show
tables
select the command and click on the
execute button
these are the tables that are stored in
this mysql database
that is columns underscore drive
component dp
and much more so now we will see what
components are stored in
these tables so we'll select one table
that would be component
and we'll see what are the columns and
what values are stored
in it to see that we will run a command
select star
from components
and now we have run this command
and what we will see is that the table
has three columns that is component id
component group id component url
but there are no values there are null
values in the table
now now we will write a command to
create
a table now we will create a table in
the mysql database
for creating the table the syntax is
create table
table name and then we'll start with the
round brackets
and then we'll write the column name and
then what column it is
whether it's int or where care so now we
will write the command
create table and we will name the table
as
persons and we'll start the round
bracket and first column would be
person id okay
[Music]
and what type it would be it would be in
type
coma and the next column would be first
name
and its type would be where
and the next column it would be the last
name
same type bad care
and the last column we would write
as city
now we'll run this command
and see that that table has been created
create table persons person id first
name where care
name vector ct wirecare so yeah
now we'll insert the values first we'll
see
what components are there in this table
select star from
persons now we will execute this command
now what would we see is that the table
is created
and all the columns are there but there
are no values so we'll insert the values
and then see the table so to
do that we'll run the commands that
would be insert into
table that is persons
[Music]
then values
then we'll start the round bracket and
write the values according to the column
names so i will write one
as the person id then comma
space and then i will write first name
that would i write would be
and we have to put these back into
commas
not an inverted commas on a single
commas you can
run this command
yeah it's been inserted into the table
persons
so first we will see whether it's
inserted or not
select star from
persons semicolon
yeah we can see the result our first row
has been inserted
now we'll insert some more rows and then
we'll some other commands
so we'll copy this
paste here and just change the values
person 82
now we will insert virat
kohli and he's also from delhi so it
would
let it remain the same
we'll execute this command it's also
been inserted into the table
and we'll write more commands
a little bit
and
one more row
looking for heart panda
we will execute this command now we have
inserted four rows into the table
and write a command to see whether four
rows are inserted or not
now we'll see another command to get out
the result with the condition
let's do that select star
from persons and what condition we
should put would be
we would obtain the two rows with the
persons
living in the city delhi so we will
write the command
select star from persons where
city
the two rows with the persons living in
the city delhi
that is kotham and virat
now we'll see a command to obtain only a
column from the table
that would be select column name
that we will select first name
first name from table name
that is persons
semicolon and now we'll run this command
so what we have got is that is the
column
first name from the table persons
with that we have come to the end of
this session i hope it was interesting
and informative
if you liked it please let us know in
the comment section also do subscribe to
our channel and stay tuned for more from
cincinnati
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here